[موسيقى]
يلا
بلشت بدايتي قبل عشر سنين في اقتناء اول
طير ببغاء اللي هو
من الفصيله الجاكو او الكاسكو وبلشت اشتغل
على اني انا اعمل منها مزرعه واخليهم
يتكاثروا واخليهم شو اسمه وهذا الموضوع ما
كان سهل علي بالمره نظرا لانه ما في عنا
خبره في البلد هون في هذه في هذه الطيور
اللي هي تعتبر من اجمل الطيور المتكلمه
والفها للانسان
[موسيقى]
اللي احببني فيه انه الببغاء عنده ذكاء
بوصل العمر خمس سنين طفل خمس سنين
نوعيات كثير منهم قادره للتحدث لتقليد
الاصوات
نوعياته كل فصيل له ميزات
فصيل زي الكوكاتو مشهور في اللعب مشهور في
الحركات البهلوانيه في عندك مثلا المكاوي
المكاوي في الضخامه وفي الجمال وفي الريش
قادر على التحدث ولكن مش كلمات كثيره عندك
اللي جاكو مولع جدا في صاحبه متحدث كثير
ممكن يعني يقلد لك اصوات كتير وياخذ لك نت
صاحب البيت
يعني هي التجربه حلوه بس المصاعب اللي
بنواجهها في هذه التربيه انه
انك تخليهم يتقاتلوا مش من الاشي السهل
ليش لانه انت بدك تحصل على ببغك عشان تعرف
اذا ذكر او انثى بلزمك تحليل دم على اساس
انك تعرف انه هذا الذكر او انثى العمر مهم
جدا مثلا نيجي نحكي على الكاسكو بتكاثر
على عمر سبع سنوات ثمان سنوات الانثى
بتتكاثر بلش التكاثر على 3 سنوات فهذا شيء
مهم كثير
[موسيقى]
في لهم جمال انهم هم بعطوا الفله للانسان
يعني انه هذا بيعطيك انه
في تفاعل في ود في ارتباط بعكس الطيور
الثانيه
[موسيقى]
انا احطهم فيها
واستغلها للشغل الثاني يعني
[موسيقى]
هلا اذا صار مرض بقدر اني اعالجه يعني
بتوفيق من ربنا يعني انه شو بقدر اني
اسويه شو اسمه شو بتعطيني خبرتي بقدر اسوي
بس انا
يعني من فتره من فتره طويله بشرى على
الوقايه الوقايه اللي هي النظافه الدائمه
بنعطيه الفيتامينات وبركز دائما دائما
وبنصح كل الناس انها تروح
للفيتامينات الطبيعيه
التشكيل الغذائي دائما تشكيل الغذائي في
ناس مثلا
بزر بزر بزر بزر لا بدك طعمها
فستق بدك طعم تفاح بدك طعم انجاص بدك
تطعمي يعني بدك تشكل تشكيله غذائي كامل
وتحافظ عليه في
ثلاث شغلات ممنوعات يعني الشوكولاته تعتبر
سم بالنسبه لعطيل الببغاء والابوكاتو هذه
من المحرمات يعني وطبعا في كمان شغله
بتاثر ولسا ما اثبتوها ميه بالميه بس انا
معي صارت بزر التفاح نفسه يعتبر من السمنه
القاتل
[موسيقى]